what's going on guys this is Rob and if
any of you guys were like me after
initially reading convergence issue
number zero we're kind of confused you
were kind of like okay I mean this is
interesting but where does this fit in
with the whole continuity I don't really
understand what's going on here is Dan
jordan's just kind of losing his mind
the question was how does this fit in
how does a story fit into the continuity
and it felt like kind of a weird place
to launch the conversion convergence
event and so what we're going to do is
we're going to explain this I'm going to
try to make this make sense to you guys
and do it in a way to where hopefully
when this video is over you'll have a
good idea of where we stand going
forward into the convergence event
proper so for those of you guys who have
read Superman doomed we're going to
lightly touch on this so you can go
ahead and stand up click the annotation
on the screen and it'll give you the
ability to skip forward past this and
into the conversation about conversions
proper but for those of you guys who
haven't Superman doomed is kind of
important here the reason because
convergence kind of fits into the
Superman doom timeline the Superman
doomed event was basically the first
time that we saw in the new 52 or
Superman fought doomsday now it wasn't
the first appearance of doomsday we had
seen him already we got his backstory
with regards to Krypton his conflict
with General Zod his I guess isolation
to the Phantom Zone his return when he
had attacked Wonder Woman and then of
course he was I appeared to be reice
elated back to the Phantom Zone again
but Superman doomed doomed doomed say
it's only just shown up he had basically
just began attacking I guess various
cities and so on and killing different
things and so it was basically the first
time the Superman in doomsday fight in
the new 52 and so we knew that was going
to sell a whole bunch of comics and
actually did pretty well it was a pretty
pretty successful series by Greg Pak and
I would go as far as to say maybe some
of his best writing since magneto
Testament but the fact remains here that
what this story gives us is the
circumstance involving how it is that
Superman basically begins to
metamorphosize into doomsday because
this is what happens Superman basically
becomes doomsday now we learn throughout
the story the Superman was infected with
this kind of I guess virus be the best
way to explain it but he was basically
infected by Brainiac with doomsday
proper so that Superman would begin to
take on the I guess the very
angry or I guess a very engaging element
of doomsday he would basically begin to
attack people who become more and more
angry all the time he would overreact to
situations to the point where he
actually began to physically look like
doomsday so it was kind of this Superman
doomsday hybrid now ultimately this is
overcome and that I guess as the story
begins to come to an end that Superman
takes this version of Brainiac which is
vril dox and flies them into a black
hole to basically try to destroy him but
as a result what we do is we basically
jump into convergence issue number zero
this is where convergence issue number
zero starts what happens is that when
Superman enters this black hole that he
basically begins to speak with what
appears to be the true Brainiac of the
Brainiac that apparently has been
existing outside of all space in time
now we're not explicitly told how it is
this Brading ike exists or where this
Brainiac came from but one of the really
cool ideas that i actually heard from
hybrid comics which if you guys don't
know who i becoming says there's a link
to him down in the description he had
talked about how various people the DC
community believed that this version of
Brainiac is an amalgamation of every
Brainiac that's ever existed in the
entire DC multiverse that he is an
amalgamation of all these different
brainiacs now we don't know this for a
fact but what's basically happening here
is Brainiac is telling Superman that
vril dox is gone and because real DOX is
a version of Brainiac it seems as though
he may have been I guess swept into or
pulled into this kind of amalgamation
Brainiac where this mega Brainiac and
that's pretty much where he resides now
but the fact remains that what Brainiac
basically tells Superman here is that in
every reality that I guess the Brainiac
is aware of that Superman's dead the
Superman had died fighting doom that
Superman had successfully defeated that
version of Brainiac there's never been
an instance where Superman has never
been in some capacity able to defeat
Brainiac and so the result is that we're
basically seeing all these different
alternate realities of Superman where
Superman dies and so it seems as though
a brainiac is telling us is that this
Superman for the new 52 is the only
Superman left alive he's the only
Superman that hasn't died yet now this
may very well be kind of a bluff on
behalf
of Brainiac we actually don't know this
yet but this is kind of compounded on
and kind of verified a little bit when
we see the Superman begins to break free
of his chains and the reason why is
because what Brainiac says is that he's
basically been traversing the multiverse
and been going after various cities and
that he plans to go after earth prime
where I guess or the I guess earth one
he plans to go after the homeworld I
guess the whole metropolis of the new 52
Superman and so what happens here is
that once Superman realizes this when
Brainiac disappears Superman's main goal
is to escape his confines and to go back
and ensure metropolis is safe but once
he actually exits this imprisonment I
guess of Brainiac he walks out into a
world that he has no idea about now
initially he starts to see someone he
believes he sees someone but when he
actually begins to speak with this
person it's a version of Brainiac and
this is where fans became extremely
confused and so we're going to kind of
take this in segments and at the end of
this hopefully it'll all make sense what
happens is that casting aside if you
will the mega Brainiac and just focusing
on these versions of Brainiac that will
see the Superman is effectively taken
through all these different versions of
Metropolis not in the sense that he goes
through each individual city intricately
but in the sense that he's basically
told by this by Brainiac and the
versions that we'll see him turning into
which is effectively all the brainiacs
that we've seen in DC continuity as well
as in the animated series that this
world houses a multitude of versions of
Metropolis but that each one of these
versions of Metropolis does not have a
Superman in it which really again kind
of ties into what it was that the mega
Brainiac was saying and that Superman
has basically died then every single
reality except for new 52 and so again
what basically happens here is that that
Superman has offered the choice of which
metropolis he wants he's told he could
have virtually any one of these
metropolis or I guess metropolis is I'm
not sure how you pronounce metropolis as
a plural but but he's told he can have
any one of these cities that he can live
in any one of these cities but Superman
declines and saying that is not his
version of
and so what seems to happen here is that
Brainiac seems to kind of turncoat and
say that if Superman won't accept any of
these metropolis as any of these
versions of Metropolis
then he has no true city on this world
and if he has no true city on this world
he doesn't belong on this world and so
they basically cast him out and this is
when Superman doomed picks back up again
this is why a lot of you guys who had
looked at Superman doomed as a story
progressed and said okay when Superman
comes out of the black hole why is he so
worried about metropolis and why does he
look like he's older this is the reason
why because this is what happened when
he flew into the black hole now with
regards to the planet itself the world
that he was on what had been told to us
I guess at some point while the
brainiacs were talking with Superman is
that this planet was sentient that this
planet was basically a planet that could
think for itself it was kind of a
perfect world that existed somewhere in
the multiverse and that the mega
Brainiac that had been existing outside
of space and time had come across this
world and noted sits I guess noticed
it's a particularly usefulness and so
what he did was began to basically
terraform this planet so that it could
sustain all the different realities that
we're going to be put on it by Brainiac
and then the planet was taken outside of
space and time the reason for this was
because as Brainiac began to add worlds
to this planet
Brainiac needed to ensure that the
people on this planet didn't age and so
by removing them from all space and time
he could basically take what would
amount to millions of years in order to
add places or add cities to this planet
but then nobody on this planet would age
now when I say millions of years that's
just kind of a number thrown out there
I'm not saying it actually took that
long that's just an example to give you
an idea of how much time could pass
without anybody actually aging because
time doesn't exist where this planet is
located now the other thing we learn
here is that all these verses of
brainiacs as Superman had seen were not
actually Brainiac or at least they
didn't appear to be Brady act instead
they begin to sort of dissolve and then
they take on the form of a villain named
Talos now Talos is a new character we
don't really know anything about this
guy yet all we know is that he's
basically going to be the person who is
effectively opening these domes and
causing all these different realities to
fight one another to conflict with one
another but again
we don't really know anything about him
we'll probably learn more about him as
time progresses with regards to
convergence proper but this video again
was basically this kind of subbing the
purpose of helping you guys understand
where we look at or I guess where we
exists with convergence issue number
zero now the final point that I want to
make here is that the idea of
convergence as a whole the basis behind
what it is a brainiac is doing is best
given I guess or is best analyzed when
you look at Brainiac as you the reader
and what I mean by this is that let's
say for example that you had been
reading comics since the 1980s since I
guess maybe right after crisis on
Infinite Earths
or maybe a little bit before crisis on
and let's say that some of the best
stories you had read are sitting on a
shelf in your home this is exactly what
Brainiac is doing Brainiac is going
through the entire DC multiverse the
entire DC Timescape every single story
that's ever existed in DC continuity and
he's taking what he perceives to be the
best ones and he's putting them on this
world and then Tilos appears to be the
one who is opening the domes and
allowing everybody to fight one another
but again I think I think makes things a
little more easier if you look at it as
though Brainiac is you the reader and
that the worlds that Brainiac is placing
or I guess the reality is Brainiac is
placing on this world our equivalent to
the stories that you've read as a reader
but again I don't know if that maybe
confuse you a little more or cleared
things up I hope it cleared things up
but again with that being said I'm gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
I don't want to get I guess too crazy
and too far out there I want to go ahead
and just kind of keep it simple but let
me know down in the comments section if
this helped you out if this was able to
clarify things for you and if it didn't
then ask your questions and I'll do what
I can to try to clarify it a little more
with that being said I will catch you
guys later peace
[Music]